ganz kurze quizfrage was ist aktuell
noch kaputter als die bundeswehr richtig
die karriere von ursula von der leyen ja
es könnte eng werden für flinte nushi
seit letzter woche gibt es einen
untersuchungsausschuss zur sogenannten
berater affäre im
verteidigungsministerium über 200
millionen euro soll sie seit 2005 10 für
externe berater verballert haben und
dabei wurde wohl mehrmals eklatant gegen
vergaberichtlinien verstoßen heißt es
sogar der vorwurf der vetternwirtschaft
steht im raum
die halle ist richtig gemacht nein jetzt
sei man nicht so hast du dir selber
uschi ihr habt doch bestimmt irgendwann
auch mal was richtig gemacht
schade schade tatsächlich ist die zahl
der berater in allen ihren ministerien
jeweils explodiert auch als arbeits und
familienministerin sie delegiert
offenbar gern arbeit und verantwortung
und zwar von meinem geld nur ein
beispiel um die frage zu klären welche
möbel für kasernen gekauft werden sollen
ist offenbar einem gutachten im wert von
1,3 millionen euro in auftrag gegeben
worden und es hat sich gelohnt
1,3 millionen euro dafür dass ein
berater sagt kommen wir klauen
etagenbett vom sperrmüll und uscis
berater armee ist ja kein einzelfall das
ganze system berater hat sich in berlin
völlig verselbstständigt berater von
firmen wie mckinsey oder roland berger
schreiben rentenkonzept das heißt die
machen politik für so schätzt man bis zu
drei milliarden euro steuern kohle im
jahr
wenn es wenigstens was bringen würde
viele soldaten tragen bei übungen wie
dieser ihre eigenen wintersachen auch
das walkie talkies privat das einzige
funkgerät ist seit monaten kaputt
natürlich natürlich hier ich habe noch
ein altes kinderlied hoffen dass da kauf
ich den ski freunde
hier seien besser
mal
doch das ist doch irrsinn ich frage mich
kriegen die beim bund überhaupt noch was
geregelt ohne berater ich glaube dass da
hinten ist ein taliban
doch nicht zu sehen
[Applaus]
für bestimmte sachen laufen ja
vielleicht berater cyber fragen oder
sogar deutschland ist auf dem weg in die
berater republik nicht übertrieben wir
schalten mal ins
verteidigungsministerium zu alexander
wipprecht er arbeitet für die firma
mckinsey als head of steuergeld
abgreifen
david precht ist der deutsche staat
regelrecht abhängig von solchen beratern
wie ihn also sorry ich hab mich ja ganz
bewusst für den beruf des
unternehmensberaters entschieden weil
das ein sozialer beruf ist so wie
altenpflege oder behinderten fahrdienst
die banken hier oder wie ich sie nenne
unsere patienten die kriegen ja ohne
beratung praktisch nichts mehr geregelt
herr staatssekretär zuerst die hose und
dann die schuhe
wir haben darüber gesprochen dadurch
dass sie jetzt nichts mehr selber
entscheiden entwickeln sich die beamten
natürlich zurück das ist umgekehrte
evolution und rückwärts aber ganz
ehrlich wieso geht denn heute überhaupt
noch irgendeiner freiwillig in den
öffentlichen dienst neulich haben die
mckinsey kollegen und ich hier schon
einmal die gehaltsabrechnung gefunden
der stunde was sie im monat
oder ihr kassiert tagessätze von bis zu
12.000 euro wofür denn bitte eigentlich
so easy peasy erklären könnte dann wäre
sie ja auch berater
es ist komplex hieraus einer mckinsey
analyse für das bam zitat wir erhöhen
die hochlauf steuerung der kapazitäten
des booms durch transparenz schaffen
über die jeweils limitierenden faktoren
des hoch laufs und ableitungen daraus
resultierender steuerungs impulse klar
hier im verteidigungsministerium
formuliere ich das sind meistens micro
power point folien freunde bei euch
läuft kacke und dann kriege ich meinen
geldkoffer das ist doch irrsinn allein
der bund hat in den letzten zehn jahren
50.000 stellen gestrichen
jetzt kaufen wir uns die kompetenz die
wir so eingespart haben für viel mehr
geld wieder ein das kann doch so nicht
weiter gehen völlig richtig völlig
richtig bin ich komplett beiden werken
wir müssen die letzten banken zahlen
unterstreichen die vögel hatten und uns
in die luft wirkt hier
das war bis neulich noch die abteilung
marine logistik habe ich komme dann
rausgeschmissen und ersetzt durch
staubsaugerroboter nicht nur besser die
sind nur noch billiger so wer bringt mir
denn jetzt mal geld kaufen
ihr könnt mir her bist du ein phänomen
auf eilige kommerz er sollte jetzt komm
her
alexander wie bringe ich meine damen und
herren
klickt hier für weitere heute schon
videos und clips moment
und klickt hier um den channel zu
abonnieren
[Musik]